en un contexto de intensas tensiones
entre parís y bamako y frente a una
audiencia de diplomáticos el primer
ministro maliense sobre el maga culpó a
francia de haber buscado la partición de
su país cuando intervino nueve años
atrás contra los avances yihadistas en
el norte
recordamos que la intervención militar
francesa después de haber ayudado
inicialmente a repeler a los grupos
terroristas se convirtió en una segunda
fase en una división de facto de malí y
creó un santuario para los terroristas y
ensanchar culturas desde que la
comunidad económica de los estados de
áfrica occidental cedeao impuso
sanciones a mali el mes pasado la junta
insiste en la soberanía del territorio
maliense y alega que francia utilizó a
la cedeao como instrumento
se han decretado medidas injustas y
salvajes con el objetivo de asfixiar a
mali de presentarlo como un paria entre
las naciones hermanas con el objetivo no
reconocido e inconfesable a corto plazo
de asfixiar su economía por su parte
francia acusa la junta militar maliense
de retrasar el regreso de los civiles al
poder y de recurrir al grupo mercenario
wagner supuestamente relacionado con el
kremlin para desestabilizar el país algo
que el presidente ruso niega
ya he dicho que el estado ruso no tiene
ninguna relación con la empresa wagner
lo repito aquí con total transparencia y
sin segundas intenciones
el primer ministro maliense no llegó a
pedir la retirada total de los militares
franceses del territorio pero con el
deterioro de las relaciones y tras la
expulsión la semana pasada del embajador
francés de mali parís afirmó que
revisara el futuro de su presencia en el
país africano